what's up guys Nick here filling in for
Eric for Fortnite battle royale week 9
challenges this week seems to be pretty
straightforward there are a couple of
interesting items that we're gonna go
over in this video but let's go ahead
and get right into what kind of
challenges we have so the first is deal
damage to opponents structures search
chests in haunted hills build structures
visit three different taco shops in a
single match follow the treasure map
found in moisty mire shotgun
eliminations and then finally eliminate
opponents in lucky landing so like I
said a lot of these are pretty
straightforward but we'll go ahead and
get right into the three taco shops in a
single match and then get back into the
treasure map found in moisty mire so
let's get right into it
alright guys so there are five taco shop
locations throughout the map here the
first starting in tomato town there is a
second somewhere within retail row there
is a third kind of down below shifty
shafts there's a fourth located until
two towers and then finally to the left
of tilta towers is our fifth and final
taco shop which is right here kind of
between snobby shores and tilted so my
suggestion is to start kind of to the
left of tilted work your way into tilted
and then finally end down below shifty
shafts so I'm gonna go ahead and try to
land somewhere around here for that
first taco shop alright so here we are
kind of landing down towards the left of
Tilted and as you can see that yellow
topped building the green kind of awning
there this is our first taco shop
alright so let's go ahead and go inside
make sure all right we visited our first
taco shop let's let's make moves towards
tilted for our second spot now so now we
are headed into tilted a little bit more
of a dangerous area hopefully we can
make it to the taco shop safely I
believe it should be right here in the
corner I'm looking at
grabs this stuff maybe protect ourselves
but I believe that's the taco shop right
there on the corner all right so again
we're in tilted towers kind of to the
left hand side and here is the second
taco shop yes all right so we could go
inside and then we will get the heck out
of here because tilted is scary all
right guys we made our way safely
through shifty shafts had a little bit
of a battle there it's all good but as
the circle closes were coming up on our
third and final taco shop and there she
is all right so we've made it through
all three taco shops this should
register that challenge once we complete
this match but again there are five
locations I'll go over those five now
just to reiterate where they are so
there are five locations one is in
tomato town kind of looks like towards
the north one is kind of off to the left
of retail row one is where we are right
now right below shifty shafts there is
one in the corner here kind of on the
left side of tilted towers and then
finally there's one off to the left in
between tilted and snobby right here so
I suggest going to the one next to
tilted where your weight into tilted
towers and then finally end up where we
are here below shifty I think these
three are the closest in proximity to
each other which makes it easier for you
guys to kind of make it through there
quickly and then get right back into the
battle royale aspect of everything all
right so next up we're gonna go over the
treasure map in moisty mire so let's get
right into that one
okay guys so here we are kind of landing
towards the center of moisty mire we're
gonna go ahead and take a look at the
map first for those of you who might not
want
you have things spoiled where the the
answer is right away and who might want
to figure out the challenge on your own
so the map is located kind of in the
center of moisty Meijer near the largest
structure so here we go so we're kind of
landing right there you can see the map
of the background all right so here is
the map so we see a house with trees
kind of triangular to round it some
footsteps and then another house with
two chimneys so we're gonna go ahead and
skip forward and try to figure out what
this means but if you guys want to solve
it that's the map and you could go ahead
and do that on your own if not we're
gonna go ahead and show you where the
exact location is now so we've made our
way kind of towards retail row it's a
little bit below into the left and as
you'll see the blue marker right here
that is the exact location of the house
with the two chimneys so we're gonna go
up here and go ahead and collect a
reward now I have noticed online that
some players are saying that they can't
pick up the the star here looks like I
had no problem but for those of you who
may have had trouble getting the the
star to like kind of dissipate when you
pick it up no need to worry
it still registers you don't have to
worry about it not counting towards your
weekly challenges so again we are below
retail row Oh sounds like somebody's
here
gotcha all right sorry about the delay
there had to focus all right so we are
right below retail row I'll go ahead and
show you guys the map one more time
there it is oh I'm done right below
retail row to the left alright guys so
as we kind of wrap things up here for
the week nine challenges we'll go over
some of the more self-explanatory ones
deal damage to opponents structures
build structures shock on the limbs
eliminate opponents and lucky landing
those are also pretty straightforward
I'm headed over to the Haunted Hills now
to try to grab some of the seven chests
you need to collect but just as a
reminder there's a lot going on right
now in fortnight battle rail we have the
50 V 50 version 2 mode that's out now
and ready to play add a little bit of a
delay but it's here now so definitely
check that out the first iteration of it
was super super fun mode so I'm gonna
definitely be diving into that and be
sure to check out gamespot.com and
GameSpot's youtube for some gameplay
from 50 v 50 and then finally for those
of you who might not have done it yet
when you sign in today you will find
some belts arms 20 battle stars that
will help you boost it actually put me
over the edge
to finally attain the John wick kind of
skin here you see and so don't forget
when you sign in you'll automatically
grab it it's pretty awesome it's
definitely a very cool thing for epic to
do I'm not sure whether it was related
to kind of the outages we saw this
weekend or not but really appreciate
epic doing that for us and again I want
to thank you guys for joining me I want
to thank you guys
support and we'll see you guys for week
ten challenges alright guys thank you
and we will see you next time